Hey how's it going guys matt from code
tech and tutorials here and i just
wanted to make a quick video answer a
comment a question that I get every once
in a while
seems to keep popping up I actually I
think I made a video on this a long time
ago but my view on it may have changed
so I'm just gonna do it again
rather than reference 8 to your old
video and the question is I don't have
it up in front of me but it's something
along the lines of is the best way to
learn how to code to go to college or
would you recommend going to school to
learn how to code and maybe I can ask
this because that's basically what I did
when I decided I wanted to be a
programmer I signed up for computer
science pretty much as soon as I could
because that oh I did some research on
the subject and you know I found the
answer that you've probably already
found that sure you can learn it on your
own you can go take little side courses
you can follow tutorials you can try to
figure out the stuff on your own
but the problem with that is well you
might figure out some basics of some
languages and stuff but there's gonna be
a lot of knowledge gaps depending on
what you're learning exactly so the
thing about taking computer science well
it was also my position the word where I
was at in my life at the time I had
already worked a lot of different a lot
of different jobs but never any
programming jobs but once I kind of
discovered that what I wanted to do was
programming I knew that I wanted to get
a programming job basically
so to transition from like a computer
tech or add I could an IT technician the
desktop technician which is basically
what I was - a lot of you know just like
troubleshooting software figuring out
what's wrong with computers fixing the
broken stuff or setups and you know just
a lot of stuff like that and I basically
made a career out of it it was it was
not bad and I was working at a
university doing it so imagine that
imagine working at a university
having a university degree that's that's
the position I was put in so he came a
little odd at times when all all like
all of my colleagues had degrees so
anyone I would talk to they would say oh
yeah I already got a degree in this I
got a degree in this and I'm thinking
about I got nothing no no I don't know
how I ended up work at Birth school
without actually going to school but uh
see I went back to school after
basically taking like a ten year break
off of school initially right out of
high school I went to DeVry University
and drie University is one of those rush
you through engineering schools that get
tried to get you a four-year degree in
three years and that sounded great cuz I
was like yeah whatever I guess I just
want to be done you know that was I was
trying to just pick the best option
whatever sounded the best when I was
young but what I didn't realize is that
I I wasn't gonna like it I got I got
into bright I took a few semesters it's
feeling pretty miserable about the
courses overall and about the content I
went from computer engineering to
computer science we were programming in
Java we you know I had some cool classes
but overall I just wasn't feeling it at
the time I didn't really understand
programming or why I would need to do it
at the time I didn't find out for myself
that I wanted to be a programmer at the
time I really had no idea so I felt like
I was kind of spinning my wheels at
school and I was also very expensive to
rise pretty expensive I guess all
schools are really but I didn't have the
finance financial backing to keep paying
for these semesters and just seeing all
the stat rack up I was like enough
Sanath I quit I'm just gonna go work so
I did that and I you know I was a
technician for years but you know
growing up I really liked videogames and
I always thought hey I want to make my
own game I had been doing it with paper
I'd played a lot of strategy games I
played a lot of competitive fighting
games I played Magic the Gathering semi
competitively I was very I had a very
strategic mind and a very calculating
mind and that's like exactly what you
want as a programmer but I didn't really
realize that and I was sort of stuck in
you know I was just kind of stuck with
what I was handed I wasn't I wasn't all
that motivated for a long time and I was
just saying okay I'll just get the
job I can kind of with what I got and
see where it goes and just keep learning
and that was all going pretty good then
one day you know when I was thirty it
just it just clicked it just it was like
it was I almost want to say it was
overnight you know I was I was working
at this job I was answering phones all
day I was doing tech support and it was
really wearing on me I had done it for
about a year a little over a year and I
was just so tired of answering phones so
tired of troubleshooting little basic
computer issues and it just wasn't
satisfying my creative need I really had
this creative drive where I wanted to
create something and I I I couldn't
figure out how to do it I would try I
tried being a musician I was in a few
bands few different bands did a lot of
touring and playing and that was pretty
satisfying but it didn't yeah I was
joining other peoples bands I wasn't
really writing a whole lot I was mostly
just kind of filling in for whatever
band I was joining so that wasn't all
that satisfying so I just had this like
artistic need to create something in I
was so in the computers you know I was
always on my computer I was always doing
stuff I was always editing things I was
out in the music editing I got into
trying to make some games and then very
quickly learn that I don't understand
how to do this programming thing I got
into cryptocurrency a lot and tried to
make my own coin and I was just like in
over my head like I don't know how to do
this code thing so it just clicked one
day that you know if I really want to be
this kind of creator that I keep trying
to be and if I really want to understand
the hardware of these computers I need
to dig in and did some research and one
of the best things that I found was
basically look if you want and
well-rounded core knowledge about how
computers work you should go for
computer engineering or computer science
and since I was more tangled towards
programming rather than the engineering
of the little electronics inside a
computer
I picked computer science now computer
science does cover a lot of the
electronics side but it sort of focuses
and also on how the software interacts
with it so it fills it I basically
wanted to fill in as many gaps
as possible and while I knew that I
could go online and I could kind of
figure some things out I could tell that
I would be missing a lot of things and
it turns out I was right I got to my
very first class when Mike my college
started and I was that was the oldest
person in there imagine imagine starting
as a freshman basically at a university
known for for young kids going in so I
was like a 30 year old in this class and
there was a bunch of 18 19 year olds and
I felt really old but looking back I'm
so glad I did it and actually I don't
think anybody realized my age I think
most people thought I was like 24 or
something because I just tend to have a
young look yeah that's just something
I've always had I guess going for me I
don't know if it really means a whole
lot but people always think I'm younger
than I am
so I kind of fit in ok with most of the
students I made friends decently easy
but all Haga honestly I wasn't really
trying to make friends at that point in
my life I was like look I'm going to
college I'm paying for it out of my own
pocket I don't want any dad out of this
I just want the knowledge so I was there
to get to get stuff done I wasn't there
to make friends I wasn't there to party
I didn't so I didn't really try to
interact with you know that crowd very
much but luckily a lot of the other kids
in computer science they were kind of
kind of group there were definitely some
kids that you know we're in it for the
computer science and those were the ones
I liked you know yeah kids you could
tell we're smart and we're actually
trying to learn this stuff too and then
there was a hole actually quite a large
group I would say the vast majority that
didn't give a crap about school or
knowledge or anything they were just
kind of there to appease their parents
or something and you know they would put
off every bit of work and just party
instead and I guess I did my fair share
of procrastination but ultimately I
didn't agree with that style at the time
back when I was at DeVry that's that's
what I wanted to do I basically wanted
to party and hang out and that wasn't
happening at DeVry so was another one of
the reasons I couldn't stay there sure a
lot of stuff happened in between I'm
cutting like a ton of this story ton of
my experience but yeah that's that's
that's basically it I just kind of came
to the conclusion that I want to do well
didn't knowledge and the knowledge about
about computers and science and
programming so yeah one of my first
classes was intro to computer science it
was C++ cat class and I loved it I did
pretty well on it it was my first real
study of a language you know a C++ so
that's kind of where my love for C++
started just just kind of see in it and
be in realizing that you can do anything
with this like blew my mind I was like
you could do anything anything I can
just edit the memory and just learning
about the memory and how it all lines up
and how the variables are certain memory
sizes it was just absolutely fascinating
to me apparently I was sort of alone in
that because about halfway through the
semester I observed that about about
half the kids weren't showing up anymore
so only about half of that class even
kept going which at the time blew my
mind I was like how could you not love
this this is like one of the most
amazing things I've ever signed up for
it was just it was like it was like
getting a key to unlock my dreams that
that's kind of what it felt like going
to that class and as I kept taking
science classes it was four years eight
semesters in a row basically I went and
it was brutal it was full-time you know
I had I had full-time work and full-time
school going on for about four years
straight now at the end of my school I
did quit my job so I could focus
full-time on my on my last year and a
half because it was getting difficult
and I was very concerned that I might
start failing courses I was getting
burnout I was running out of time I was
barely able to get stuff done just with
my with my schedule I also had a kid at
the time a new kid so that was taking up
time too so I made the decision to to
dip into my savings a little bit to
invest in my future and say look I'm
gonna quit work I'm gonna finish my
school do the best I can learn all I can
and then go from there and that's what I
did a lot of computer science courses a
lot of English courses a lot of math
courses chemistry psychology a bunch of
other courses
so that's the thing sure you can even
learn how to code you can learn the
basics of computer science by
researching online but yeah it doesn't
you don't really get that great of a
path you get someone's idea of a path
but a curriculum from a school it's it's
been well studied it's like a you know
it's a well studied curriculum it's wet
it's kind of what they set up for you to
succeed you know like yeah you gotta you
gotta be good at public speaking at a
job you got to be good at writing you
got to know all the basics of this stuff
if you don't want to look like a fool at
your job being good at computer science
is great but also being good at dealing
with people and having over kind of a
wide you know just having all that your
generals class like understanding the
basic psychology of people was rather
important to I also had a really I've
had a had a pretty big interest in
psychology too never really went to
school for that but I've always studied
psychology on my own I'm always
fascinated by psychological studies and
so maybe that was a bit of a part of it
too cuz it was kind of something you
could I don't know it was just it was
just interesting in a weird way it felt
like it was like the programming of the
human mind or something it was it was
very abstract but it was something I
really enjoyed so yeah when I went to
school I I very specifically thought
look I want to be a programmer I want to
make games I want to write the functions
behind the games that control how how
things work together that's that's what
I that's what I thought but I really
signed up for a lot more than that
because while I got that I also got a
lot of other lessons life lessons you
know just going through all that going
through old projects made a big
difference like that four years of my
life ramped me up a lot and it it really
set me on the right path to to start
doing good things like right out of
school I got a I got a job at a research
company and it was it was going great I
was doing the back end code of C++ stuff
and I was in over my head to be honest
but they seemed to like me there I was
able to get some new features in with
the code
and what was that hard like that was one
of the most challenging jobs and I was
really you know I was surprised they
hired me because you know I was it was
like I wasn't my first edge deaf job I
had a had a deaf job while I was in
school too so but it wasn't that
structured so this was like my first
real dev job right out of school and
yeah went pretty well ultimately yeah
you know it was a job that was pretty
far away from home so it was a it was
interesting doing that dynamic and
that's actually where I recorded a lot
of my early early videos just driving
back and forth in that job cuz it was
like just long open road nothing going
on it was really boring so sometimes I
would just get thoughts churning and I
just hit record and make a video and
then I would make videos on my break
just to get out of the office but it was
it was just such a such a great
experience overall just getting in there
trying to figure out their codebase and
just getting to actually practice github
and stuff like that now while I was in
school the one thing I was not very
satisfied with was the lack of long-term
projects it was like here's a little
thing you got to do you got a week and
then once you do it you got nothing left
to do it they still don't assign you
anything else you don't have to code or
study code anymore so I started taking
it upon myself to come up with my own
projects to do in the downtime because I
couldn't I wasn't really quite good
enough to understand what was going on
and fully and other people's projects
and github ugh I would look at someone
else's project think I'm sure I'll try
to work on this to see if I can learn
some new things and I would just get
totally lost so I was like I guess I'm
gonna do my own thing I mean I know how
to start a new program I know how to had
things I know how to I know how to
generally manipulate the data but the
way other people were structuring their
code I don't understand this and maybe
they're doing it the industry-standard
way but I wasn't I was learning from the
ground up so I didn't understand the
industry standard for a long time but
doing my own projects and just keeping
at it and looking at other people's code
and then eventually learning libraries
more properly because before it was just
like okay I walked through and at the
library but I don't understand what's
actually going on
eventually I began to understand that
and you'll see that now in some of my
videos I'm always talking about
libraries I find it just absolutely it's
it's just awesome being able to to make
something and then and use it in any of
your projects in the future without
having to code it all up again so I just
I just love that about C++ that you can
just build your own libraries and then
when you come up with new ideas and good
you can just like moderately pop your
parts and now I made this program called
DM power
I started making when I was in school
and started to gain a little popularity
it's just a program for D&D I was
playing a lot of D&D with some friends
so I was getting very annoyed with
having to look up stuff in the books all
the time so I just decided hey I'll just
write a program that does all this and I
did some on github it's called the
empower I don't know everyone somehow
gets a new star I think it's got like 56
stars but you know that's not something
I've ever really you know in retrospect
it's terrible code
I was only coding for about a year when
I started that project and I went
through just a lot of trying to figure
out things and learning new things with
that and it really you know just writing
that that code base it's like I don't
know how many lines of code I want to
say it's 50,000 lines ago to this point
but that's probably an exaggeration I
don't think it's that much but it's a
lot of lines of code and that was all
done in the downtime of my college so
what I didn't have projects assigned to
me I was working on that so I was just
always coding in C++ and by my third or
fourth year everyone was coming to me
with with their questions about C++ at
school they were like hey I'm stuck on
this can you help me and I'd look at it
I mean I go just do this yeah there you
go
and so I became like the Stack Overflow
for a lot of a lot of students and
needed help I guess not a lot of them I
don't want to sound like I'm bragging
too much but I felt like I was a bit
ahead on the whole C++ realm compared to
everybody else and you know I was pretty
new to it I just learned it my first
experience with it was that first class
and you know I never really stopped I
really I really have a love for this
language it's you can just do anything
with it so it's kind of skewed my
reality a little bit like a try program
in JavaScript and I just didn't get it
like it didn't click to me but then like
then when I started learning about lamb
doesn't C++ and getting them to that and
I was like oh ja was just a bunch of
lamb does basically so that kind of
simplified it for me but I don't really
you know I don't really care to code in
Java or JavaScript rather I did spend
about a solid year studying the Java
language and doing Android programming
and that was a pretty good experience I
have a couple apps nothing super
spectacular or anything but I did do a
social media one for for school my
senior project and got it connected the
internet got chat rooms got messaging
uploading and you know getting a lot of
the social media functions were in there
so I kind of learned how to do all that
on Android and that helped me a lot so I
learned a lot about releasing and you
know getting on the Google Play Store
and some of the things you're gonna do
there so that kind of opened up some new
things for me too and I would have been
able to do any of this without school I
feel like I'd be I wouldn't quite have
the a wide-enough knowledge base to do
quite what I do now
I don't know if that makes any sense but
you know I don't feel like I'd have a
whole lot of trouble getting most
programming jobs sure I'd probably you
know I probably have to do a few
interviews but eventually I'd get one of
them and I don't really feel that
nervous about it you know for me the
problem is showing up I just need to
show up basically because I'm not all
that motivated to do day jobs anymore
I'm really more motivated to do my own
thing and do my own projects and do my
own business so that's what I do now I I
quit my that research job after about
three or four months and it wasn't
really anything to do with the work it
was just the timing and the location of
everything was not good for me so I
don't know if this is gonna answer your
question about whether you should go to
school learn code or not but I will say
that yeah going to a traditional
four-year college for computer science
will give you a
of understanding about knowledge you
know there's there's a set big there's a
lot of computer science courses you have
to go through and it steps you through
you know you get the beginner classes
get a little more difficult
you get discrete math you get parallel
programming and and you get a bunch of
other stuff you get AI classes and
they're all they're all 12 to 14 weeks
each so you get a nice chunk of time
studying this one thing and you're
studying the actual science of it the
stuff we know the stuff that's
documented the stuff that's in books and
you know you get rigorously test it on
it in assignments and it's it's really I
think a good way to open up your
knowledge if you don't have that so I I
don't think it's a bad idea the biggest
thing is the money like it costs a lot
of money good or good to go to school so
you can either go into depth for it or
hopefully you have savings and can work
it out every semester my big thing was I
didn't want to go into debt but since I
was working for the university I was
getting a decent paycheck I was getting
some putting savings for quite a while
every every every paycheck basically so
that helped and then when I signed up
for school I could fill out some
paperwork and say hey work for the
school and they would pay for some of my
tuition of course that stopped happening
when I quit the job to finish school but
you know I had to make a choice I just
it would have took me like another year
to finish if I didn't quit my job
basically so I made the choice to quit
my job and do school full-time even
though I took a bit of a hit financially
it saved me some time so that was kind
of the point of that but yeah I really
had to plan it out financially I
basically had to plan the full four
years all the costs all my expenses I
just made I had to make sure I could pay
for it I didn't I was already like a ton
in debt from that 10 year ago thing I
did it to fry that felt like a complete
waste so I was like there's no way I'm
taking any more debt and once I figured
out a way to not have to take any more
debt it's gonna eat into my savings a
little bit especially once I quit I
didn't really plan on quitting work but
it just kind of happened because I was I
was something I had to give it got to
that point and I think it was the right
choice overall I don't really have any
regrets about that
but yeah as well as soon as I was done
with school my bank account was drained
I took it right to the limit like I
barely paid off that last semester so I
didn't take any debt that was a big
thing for me but it did eat like all my
savings but I was investing in myself so
I paid off and I got a job right away
that paid really well and there were a
lot of others that opened up for me but
I just couldn't do it really more into
my own thing doing my own business and
now I'm doing this channel on YouTube
and as far as I can see it's gonna
continue I have some really exciting
videos coming up so please if you want
to see more coding videos more stuff
about code and consider subscribing to
this channel and my next one that I'm
actually working on is all about coding
up animations from scratch with C++
basically and it's been a subject that
I've been wanting to cover for a long
time but there's a lot of you know there
are a lot of levels of it and a lot of
math you have to get perfect so sure I
can I can do it all with libraries or
with a game engine or stuff but that
doesn't you know I don't understand all
the all the math if I do it that way so
that's one of the things that I kind of
got ingrained after a while is I want to
know how things work from the ground up
I want to understand the the tiny bits
that most people just abstract away
I sure I'd like to have tracked him away
but I'd like to write the code that
abstract them away so that's that's
basically what I do here is I just teach
you what I learned mostly from code I
guess most of my channel was actually
blown up from my blender tutorials just
because I you know I've done a lot of
video editing with blender I did a
gaming channel for a while and I had
pretty much edited all my videos with
blender so I got a lot of experience
with that and made made some videos
covering blender as a video editor and
that kind of made my channel blow up you
know blow up for me you know it's not
not really blow up in terms of what most
people call blow out I'm not like
Kardashian or something getting millions
of views a day it's not it's not
but you know those videos get continuous
reviews and they bring people in but I
don't know but really I made this to
talk about code codes just way too niche
to really gain mainstream well I would
say C++ code is a bit too niche to give
me a mainstream channel with it just
depends on what you want to do so
hopefully that helps that's you know I
kind of gave my story of why I
personally went to college and just
needing that direction and wanting a
well-rounded knowledge base and you know
having that degree it was nice because
everyone else I worked with had one and
it just it just felt awkward after a
while to not have one and it made sense
because I was getting a pretty big
discount or just because of my work and
then paying for it
I don't really fully agree with going to
college right after high school to be
honest to her you know that didn't work
for me that didn't feel right for me I
think people should take a year or two
off but also you know if you know you
know so follow your own heart don't
necessarily listen to me if you want to
go straight to school after high school
awesome if not I think that's fine too
and don't don't feel ashamed or whatever
if your parents ragging on you if you
want to go out and get some real-world
experience that is incredibly valuable -
that's another thing I observed when I
was in school I was miles ahead of all
the students like I knew the answers to
almost every question except for those
that involved incredibly technical mathy
stuff because I think well I haven't
ever studied that but like all the
general questions of how to handle
business and how to run things I kind of
already knew all that just from all the
work experience I had and let's see what
else happened you know like I mentioned
the cryptocurrency I once had a Bitcoin
farm I think I mentioned that in another
video once but yeah at one point I had a
Bitcoin for him and I was tweaking that
all the time and that sort of got me
interested in code - he's playing World
of Warcraft a lot I got pretty into mods
for a while that sort of got me touching
a lot of code - so there were a lot of a
lot of things that kind of led up to I
keep getting involved with code but I
don't quite have enough knowledge to
really do
and make very basic changes so just
really well that's it hope this helps
hope you have a good day
peace out everyone stay safe out there